metro also investigating a deadly
stabbing this one happened near bonanza
and mlk drive this morning our ron
futrell explains where police are now in
their investigation
police first became aware there was a
problem at this scene when a young man a
22 year old man unidentified at this
point went to the hospital with stab
wounds they were then led to the desert
garden condominiums on west bonanza
where they found the young man's father
deceased of stab wounds approximately 4
a.m this morning they were able to
locate an apartment make entry and they
did find
a deceased body of an hispanic male
we've identified that hispanic male he's
going to be a 54 year old male
who is still on the scene and has
succumbed to the injuries
neighbors in the area tell us that these
condominiums are a regular place for
drug deals for prostitution and now at
least one homicide ron futrell live
local now
police have not released the names of
the father and son involved they say the
case is still under investigation